curious about the state of css in 2022
i'm adam argyle and i'm super stoked to
break that down with y'all spoiler
though it's hot it's rapidly changing in
all the right ways and designers tune in
because there are rad goodies in here
for y'all as well but first a surprise
because we know it's hard when you get
new toys but you can't use them because
of cross browser compatibility well last
year five style features were focused on
and made it incredibly more stable
sticky positioning aspect ratio flexbox
grid and transforms a team listened and
they heard compatibility was a pain
point when developing for the web so
they hacked on it well that team in 2022
went next level
this year the major browser engines
agreed together on what to focus on i
know it's huge and not only is the list
here amazing their collective goal is to
complete them by the end of the year
just look at this list at layer color
spaces and functions containment the
dialog element form compatibility
scrolling subgrid typography viewport
units and even more web compatibility
stable features browsers hacking on them
together life is good for the web.dev
that's the surprise
so let's get nerdy and dig into what's
fresh in 2022. recently stable and first
up see the browser icons with green
underlines there is cascade layers also
known as atlayer allows you to customize
control and orchestrate the cascade
a css language feature for wrangling
asynchronous loading and third-party
styles styles can load late in a page
life cycle but be placed into an upper
layer as if they were loaded first or
second to begin with so no more
meticulously hand managed css loading
just let it load let it load whenever it
wants assign it to one of your
predefined layer nodes
for example here on the left before
atlayer style imports are grouped and
meticulously managed so they override in
the order desired but with at layer you
can define the groups in order up front
then let whatever loads later append
into a controlled cascade layer and
there's even more features of cascade
layers check it out on web.dev or mdn
for more information and also don't miss
the dev tools where you can see an
overview of all the layers
see when styles are in a layer and
layers are organized just like you'd
expect
boom subgrid this one is a huge win for
the web layout firefox has had this
feature for a while but thanks to
microsoft in the interop efforts 2022
and tends to catch up in chromium and
webkit
so designers often have page level grid
lines that they align tons of children
to well that's a capability of subgrid
there's a grid on the body of this page
with line names like full bleed and main
the paragraphs and headlines are aligned
to the main and the article image is
full bleed it's so nice and here's the
css for that grid and those defined
lines gutters are set to auto and the
main is set to 60 characters or 90 on
smaller screens the children of that
grid are given display grid too with
their columns set as their parents with
well subgrade
main content assigns itself to the main
column grid later like this and full
bleed content can span the whole page
like this wipe your hands clean and that
is it and also the dev tools for a rock
you can see which grids to find lines
and which are adopting them see the
lines on the page with their names and
their sizes
another 2022 interop effort feature is
container queries before container
queries we could adjust elements to the
page viewport without media and after
container queries we can adjust elements
to the size and styles of a container
components responding to containers
instead of containers adjusting children
components owning more of their own
styles check out this rad demo by unit
kravitz from the chrome team
event components you know like you made
a new event on a day are shown adapting
to their container day columns space so
even though the viewport is being
adjusted the components are only
watching their column size styles change
based on how much column width is
available the demo could change to a
one-day view or a three-day view and the
event components would adapt
speaking of which there's a demo that
does just that
watch the book component here it adapts
itself to each section differently
layouts and styles based on container
one component many built-in adaptions
demo credits here go to maxbox rad demo
max okay let's see some code
first you need a container that can be
queried specify what kind of queries it
supports and give it a name if you want
container type accepts inline size like
width block size like height
just size or style yeah style be able to
query a container style interesting but
for now let's focus on size and that
calendar day container
later use the act container syntax to
query that day container and see if it's
200 pixels or smaller if it's true those
elements selected inside will apply
those new styles just like media queries
you could change from square images to
rounded images card components to go
vertical or horizontal all intelligently
lots of amazing design and ux
possibilities here there's even a
polyfill so you could try today don't
miss jessalyn yin's google i o talk on
devtools it'll show you how to debug
container queries
next up is accent color available
everywhere already safely and easily
tint built-in elements
bring your brand color to your forms
with one line of css and the browser
will ensure that there's proper contrast
between your color and the check boxes
and the tracks
you can tint everything like you see
here in root or tint contextually with a
targeted selector pro tip use a media
query to check for lighter dark theme
settings and adapt your accent color to
fit better kind of like this here i
switch from hot pink to light pink for
users with their system in dark mode now
my built-in elements are adaptive and
tinted
color is exploding with features in 2022
we have new color spaces more colors
built-in color manipulation and auto
contrast functions all of which are
feature goals in interop 2022.
first up is hwb standing for hue
whiteness and blackness and it's an
intentionally humanistic way of thinking
about color
here's a quick demo overview we have
five swatches all with the same hue of
200 then i adjust the amount of white or
black in each swatch one has 75 white
with no black giving us a light blue
swatch number five has no white and 90
black a dark blue
hwb is pretty cool but there is way more
css color is about to be unchanged from
srgb the only color space that's been
available for like 25 years
10 more color spaces are coming you can
reach into these color spaces for colors
or mix and interpolate with inside of
them safari tech preview has these
already available to try
so currently css can only show colors
from that inner triangle srgb
display p3 one of the new color spaces
can show the outer triangle
other spaces can reach even further into
that color diagram than display p3 color
gamuts are the amount of colors to
choose from in a space and i like to
think of gamuts like fruit sizes think
of srgb like a kiwi and display p3 like
a mango the bigger the fruit the more
colors you have to choose from and leah
varue says these are not just any colors
but the most vivid colors the screen can
display and she's right and maybe more
colors doesn't sound that interesting
but you thought you were picking hot
pink in your color picker but if you
change the color space you're picking
from look at all those brighter colors
like in lab here get a hotter pink and
it doesn't stop at just more vibrant
colors either
with new color spaces there's also new
shapes to work within the rgb cube maybe
you've seen it is suspiciously neat
shaped hsl and some others they're
cylinders but look at cie lab on the
right there a new color space for us in
2022 it's kind of funky right it's all
stretched and contorted for different
colors it's because srgb spaces are math
driven where the shown cie space is
human perception driven hence the
imperfect shape
cie color spaces also feature
optimizations for human perception of
lightness called perceptually linear
this makes it awesome for mixing colors
like light in this color brand by 20
and it will match your human
expectations
gradients are massively influenced by
color spaces here's four gradients all
deep pink to cyan shown in four
different color spaces
srgb in the top left travels in a
straight line between the two colors
through its cube going through the
middle of the cube and making kind of
muddy colors lab and lch though on the
bottom they don't travel through this
color dead zone so you thought you were
getting beautiful web gradients but srgb
can only do so much here
here's some of the new color syntax for
accessing these new colors i call the
first lch color there ux gray because
it's 50 from a perceptually linear space
aka it's 50 gray it's not math middle
gray it's human centric middle gray then
i create a couple hot pinks picking
vibrant colors with the lab and lch
functions
then there's the color function
accepting a color space and three
numbers for each of its channels i use
it here to grab hot pinks and display p3
lab and srgb
you can progressively enhance your
colors too of course it's css the
dynamic range media query lets you know
if the device is capable of hd colors
and the at supports query checks to see
if the browser understands the color
syntax before you use it there's so much
more here to study watch out for web.dev
blog posts about it
coming to a browser near you in 2022
color mix
use css to mix colors on the fly and the
color space of your choice
to use it call color mix and give it two
colors and get an equal mix of each in
lch the default color space or pass a
percentage along with a color which
specifies how dominant the color is in
the mix the second example there uses a
brand hex base and mixes it with black
to create some darker alt colors and i
know i've been stoked on like everything
so far but this one is magic pure and
incomparable magic let the browser pick
accessible colors for you automate good
contrast
so here's four surfaces all shown with
the same paragraph content inside each
is using color contrast function with a
range of brand hues to target the ratio
aaa notice how the lightest and darkest
backgrounds get the more subtle text
colors and the brighter surfaces get
blacker white text colors i got to bake
in good contrast into my css and give it
up to the browser we let the browser
manage this this is how it works in this
first selector i created
bg variable and assign it to the
background for the text color i call the
color contrast function and pass it to
bg prop and without any options passed
color contrast will choose black or
white for me but later in some other
selector change bg and the text color
automatically picks up white or black
based on the new background color
wow
wow right and it gets better so it's
cool having black or white picked for
you but those are usually last resort
text colors for designers so check this
out i call color contrast again with a
background variable in this case a brand
blue
and then i passed three different text
colors from a design system plus a
double a target contrast ratio i used
double a here but you can also pass a
custom number
now the browser will pick the color
that's closest to passing the score
so you can just throw a bunch of text
colors at this function and it'll ensure
you pass and if none pass black or white
will be chosen for you as a fallback
rad right and there's even more color
stuff coming too
check out relative color syntax another
color game changer it allows you to
extract new colors from existing colors
let me show you
in my career so much of the color code
in my css has pivoted on a brand color
or maybe two
and in this code sample i put a
simulated brand color into a dash color
problem in the variable called abs
change short for absolute change i
create a new lch color from the variable
and set its lightness to 75
keeping the chroma and the hue i call it
an absolute change because i threw away
the lightness from the hex and gave it a
new one the var rel dash change is a
relative change example i again start a
new lch color and i keep the lightness
but i decreased the chroma by 20
keeping the blue hue and the lightness
it's a relative change because i
adjusted it relative to the source color
value i think of this relative color
syntax like destructuring in javascript
you destructure the color channels out
of the color directly into a new color
with an opportunity to manipulate each
channel along the way it's so rad it
gives me the power to create
perceptually linear palettes with very
very little code and here's what those
palettes look like that i made with the
relative color syntax and the lch color
space
i wrote the relative color logic one
time and it takes a base color and
generates a palette then i use it for
all 15 palettes here give me a brand
color and i'll give you a perceptually
linear palette back and notice how
smooth they are too no hot spots thanks
to lch that perceptually linear color
space is super handy so be stoked to see
css producing these incredible colors
and smooth palettes in the web in 2022
y'all but 10 new spaces mean 10 new
gradient variants to choose from let's
take a look
on the left are gradients simply going
from black to white and on the right are
gradients going from blue to black today
you get the top gradient the srgb
interpolation result which is generally
fine and consistent
in 2022 you'll get to pick from any of
the others below it and you see what i
mean there's 10 new gradient variants
the color space is super important the
variance in just black to white is
intriguing but the blue to black
gradients going purple or pink in the
middle what's going on there let's see a
couple more examples on the left is red
to white and some turn a bit orange one
goes pink and some go through that dead
zone in the middle on the right is blue
to white most go purple in the middle
but okay lab and lch stay nicely within
hue
interesting right so i expect designers
to start specifying which color space
they want their gradients in after they
get these tools
and here's the syntax
to linear gradient that allows you to do
this that allows you to access the color
space linear gradient you call a
function say direction to right and the
space in hsl or lch and then your set of
colors it's pretty straightforward
change with really big results last in
our color set here is color v1 fonts
they're a new smaller color font format
with embedded vectors that allow
gradient and blend mode customizations
it's an evolution of the ot svg fonts
but they're smaller and with more
options it's great for icon fonts
awesome headlines and tons more
so before color v1 fonts we had these ot
svg fonts colorful editable and really
playful but the styles are fixed
after color v1 fonts like placato here
customize the font with at font palette
values these let you define parameters
to pass into the font very similar to
variable font parameter passing you can
tailor the color font to meet your needs
and this could be a huge win for icon
fonts and more
to use them import color fonts like any
other font with an app font face
declaration or grab them from google
fonts with an add import which will
include those goodies next create an app
font palette values block with a name
colorized is used here
then specify which font you're targeting
and pass some overrides
later assign the font family with the
color font and specify the custom font
palette and that's it
next up is inert this allows developers
to specify which part of the document
should be inactive think of it like
freezing portions of the document you
can use it for keeping focus into a
certain part of the page by making other
parts of the page inactive so originally
started by alice boxhall now a gallia is
carrying it across the finish line in
2022
the alert javascript function is a good
example once that pops up the rest of
the page isn't interactive keyboard and
mouse users are being guided into the
area where their action is required
to achieve this let's look at some html
here a modal is shown and the main
element is given the inert attribute now
mouse and keyboard users have proper
focus into the modal because the main
element is frozen
no js or tab index attribute traps
required this is a really cool
accessibility win and expect to post
from it on web.dev
another goal of interop 2022 is enjoy a
bunch of new viewport unit variants that
you can really hone in that full
viewport feel
new units allow you to specify
smaller viewport size as if the mobile
tab bar is showing the larger viewport
size is if the mobile tab bar is hidden
or dynamically be both depending on the
presence of that mobile tab bar you have
20 new units to fit this viewport with
physical or logical values here's all
the new physical and logical viewport
units we have 100 vh 100 dynamic
viewport height 100 small viewport
height 100 large viewport height and
then there's the logical direction block
versions for internationally adapting
full screen layouts then the
complementary width versions and the
logical inline versions but you can't
forget the min and max viewport units
too each with small large and dynamic
versions representing either the smaller
of the viewport height or width or the
larger hopefully these unblock lots of
folks making full screen app experiences
ah colon has selector this is easiest
described as the parent selector but
that sells it short think of it more
like i'm no longer forced to have my
target element at the end of a selector
i can change the subject of the selector
if i want this one is being implemented
by a gallia recently stable in safari
and an interop goal in 2022 here's a few
examples the first selects the parent
class if it has a child in its tree this
can be amazing for a cms or layout to
know what kind of blocks it needs to
make space for
the second example selects a section
element if any of its children have
focus visible i like this example
because it shows how this selector will
affect interactivity and ui feedback
let's look at a couple more examples
the first selects anchor elements
wrapping images and the second finds
images that are inside figures with fig
captions so see how it's not just a
parent selector this last example
selects images if it's parent has
caption elements right it's amazing so
expect has to be a huge game changer
combining it with pseudo selectors and
nth match notation selectors it's going
to unlock some very powerful state and
style
quite a lucky time to be a web developer
be sure to check out my blog post on
this talk where i go into even more
detail about these topics and more items
find me on twitter web.dev and youtube
sharing gems and tips about front end ui
and css i'll see you later y'all hope
you're stoked now too
[Music]
you